tutti ragazzi e benvenuti e questo nuovo
video io sono falli j
oggi siamo tornati ragazzi sul terzo
episodio di cat mario direi di andare
avanti perché lo voglio finire prima
possibile perché voglio sentirmi un
ragazzo libero libero di tornare a il
piacere di tutti i giorni ai vecchi
videogiochi dove molti mi arrivano in 4
secondi dove non si moriva
allora ragazzi stavolta sul serio me lo
devo ricordare il bello io ci credo
anche nel senso che non lo faccio
apposta sono stupido
ma dai ragazzi io vi giorni non lo sto
facendo a posta se io vi giuro arrivato
ha rivolto a quel quadratino lì a me
viene da saltare cinque ragazzi io
veramente vista c'è mire e l'aquila
quinta latte sembra bravo bravissimo se
ti meriti un premium
ok adesso se l'ho fatto cioè adesso
diventa complicata la faccenda perché
non so come si fa a vendere
presumo si faccia così madonna madonna
no no no non ci voglio credere
avevo fatto adesso doveva vedere mai
live ai sì sì sì perché per che cosa
peccato cosa peccato cosa metto
maledizione
[Musica]
non ci credo due ore e mezzo non ci
voglio non so quanto ci ho messo ragazzi
due ore non ci voglio credere
non avete idea di quanto ci ho messo non
ci posso credere di esserci arrivato non
ci credo dimmi che già nei voti prego
dimmi che già arrivo
[Musica]
grazie dio grazie si è chiuso il gioco
ragazzi ho finito che mare un finale
veramente profondo che mi rimarrà in un
veramente nel profondo nel cuore voglio
provare a fare una pazzia che mi è
venuta in mente sul momento voglio
provare a farmi cat mario dall'inizio
alla fine senza tagliare una volta tutto
di fila voglio provare a vedere se ci
riesco vai cos'è stage 1 voglio vedere
allora già non mi ricordo più perché non
me lo ricorderò mai come era il primo
stage
ok ok madonna ok questa quadra ma sto
ricordando vela è solo fanno salto
abbastanza lungo si bene qua c'è un
tizio benissimo mio dio ragazze la
stoffa c'è a dall'acqua devo fare un
salto nel madonna si ok ma devo andare
sull'albero benissimo ragazzi ci sto
facendo prima tentativo mi sembra
impossibile
bene faceva qualcosa mi ricordo sebbene
ragazzi e già sta tutto il kit mario una
vita sola che mario in una vita sola
impossibile se ci riesco mi vogliono
voglio una statua nel centro di new york
scusatemi se mi sento rotto ma devo
aspettare che passino benissimo allora
devo credere nelle mie capacità
c'è grande ok mai così mai così vai così
adesso domandare di una prima sì sì
ragazzi ce la sto facendo noi affidato
la de lucia saltare prima si primo
livello senza morire una cosa su
benissimo ragazzi il primo episodio di
cat mario lo riassunto in alimenta
adesso perché non sono morto neanche una
volta
[Musica]
questo non vale va bene è non guardavo
lo schermo che è giusto avete capito
sono morto va bene sono morto almeno
siamo contenti tutti
vai così lancia music bene allora qua
deve cadere il primo pranzo me lo
ricordavo
ok che mi sono salvato di brutto sì
grandissima bandiera bene ok allora sta
parte non mi ricordo tutto questo me lo
ricordavo che mi ero fermato qui devo
andare magari di qua no allora non ho
idea di come si faccia perché se io vado
di quart succede che cade da fare non so
che cos'è quella roba lì ma non ce la
faccio
ho capito ok ho capito ho capito non
chiedo non dite nulla ho capito
mai così vai così vai così saliti sull i
verdetti ce l'ho fatta grandissimo
allora adesso devo andare avanti non so
niente zero da qua non c'era bene
privato già una uno di quei cose quindi
c'è un traguardo
ok beni ragazzi ed io non l'avevo fatta
questa parte non so come c'era la
bandiera lì ero arrivato alla fine
maledizione ero arrivato alla fine non
posso crederci siamo almeno tre ce la
posso fare ragazzi ce la posso fare
ho notato che oggi me la sto prendendo
stranamente poco con cat mario quindi la
prossima volta che voglio saranno cazzi
tua ok
devo riuscire a fare sta parte ciò posso
fare con molta calma scopriamo tutto
perché non mi ricordo più
ok torniamo sotto news ok ragazzi adesso
dovrei fare così credo
[Musica]
ok ragazzi ce la posso fare
non so non so se funziona ma spero di sì
sì c'è pure aver fatto ciò dovrebbe
affatto ci dovrei aver fatto ciò
dovrebbe fatta ce l'avrebbe fatta
dio mio dio mio ti ringrazio dio mio ti
ringrazio di me ringrazio ciò posso
ancora fare
siamo arrivati qui benissimo ragazzi
questo penso che me lo ricordiate
nell'ultimo livello bene allora questo è
incasinatissimo john bye bye bye bye che
l'ho già fatto una volta ragazzi tutto
tirato tutto tutto tirato vai così
grande ok ragazzi allora piano ce la
posso fare
ok quello non me lo ricordavo male non
ha fatto nulla ebbene sì madonna non so
ricordato la forse che hanno anche
questo non mi ricordano ok ma c'è un
qualcosa che c'è qualcosa qui non mi
ricordo più
no non c'è niente bene c'è grande no no
no fermo che culo che culo assurdo bene
non sono ancora vivo solo tra vivo
benissimo benissimo tutti calmy rey che
devo arrivare alla bandiera allora
l'ultimo episodio ci è arrivato per culo
perché mi ha cambiato livello ragazzi
vergani ha cambiato livello perché
questa è la volta buona raga tutto che
mario tutto tutto tutto quanto tutto
tutto un calcio tutto ci vuole
concentrazione ragazze
[Musica]
no cazzo mi sa di mentire per chi urlava
quella roba edizione cela stavo facendo
mio zio stavo facendo un'impresa da dio
veramente si si non ci credo non ci
credo
dai dai dai dai dai dai set
[Musica]
ragazzi abbiamo finito occhietti mario
che bello ci sono dodici volte ciao
benissimo questa figura di merda ma la
poteva risparmiare service è piaciuto
come al solito lasciato un commento mi
piace anche la pagina di facebook che
come ogni video tratte nella descrizione
61 senatori schiti iscrivetevi noi ci
rivediamo in un prossimo vi do addio
pezzo di merda